ich finde die sieht so aus als wird die
singen oder nicht sondern hey was geht
ab jetzt willkommen beim ein video ich
hab heute nach sehr langer zeit mal
wieder mein bruder dabei freust du dich
ja und ich habe mich für heute was schon
besonders weil ich wie immer seit ja
gewohnt von mir auf jeden fall mein
bruder guck ich ganz so viel youtube
also der kennt sich halt schon aus so
mit gewissen youtube an so ganz
bestimmte leute wie zb babys beauty
palace und sowas ist kennt man natürlich
mehr habt ihr wahrscheinlich am titel
auch schon gelesen und zwar hab ich ihr
volk überlegt ich zeig dir einfach ein
paar youtuber ein paar er einfach so
leute die man halt in der jugend
heutzutage ja die halt ein bisschen
berühmt sind meist so die man zum teil
kennen könnte und ich hoffe mir kann
keiner von uns du musst dann halt immer
erraten was dieser typ oder weißt du
sooo vom aus in die hand und so
ermitteln was die eventuell machen
könnten auf youtube die musik machen ob
die blogs machen auf die sich ausziehen
sondern sogar zwei ausziehen
jetzt hoffe ich auf youtube aus glaube
ja das ist der sinn des heutigen videos
und ich würd mal sagen mein bock habe
auflaufen teil dann würde ich mal sagen
bei wievielen 1001 10.000 12.000 ja sagt
als zehnter nur 12.000 jahr 12 dann
machen wir darum hat ja ich will gar
nicht lange glauben ich bin mal gespannt
und zwar heute nicht gucken wir fangen
erst mal ganz eigentlich noch leichter
und zwar hier mit ja also na gut das war
noch einfach so leute wir machen weiter
und zwar jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wer
ist denn wer ist denn das ganze nicht
als wenn was mainz macht er als ich ihm
bekannt so ein anderes bild vor allem
zeigen irgendwie kennt zudem einzeln ja
ja
[Musik]
keine ahnung zum klauen und so ja was
schätze dann macht er so gut wie immer
genau an was du denkst du macht er ja so
block so was du so was wie durch also
nicht singen und so gemeint welches land
wäre ja ja ja sagt das doch
kennst du von dem auto passt nicht zu
dem song von dem ich mich sogar mich
besser ok reicht so wir machen weiter
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wer ist denn
bitte
eigentlich muss man die kennen so in
seinem alter als junge wer ist dann
bitte das hier zu lasten der mann saß
ich neben der autogrammstunde autogramm
schöne nicht motorrad gramm stunde auf
youtube kennedy aber ich bin mir da
nicht ein er war über was was denkst du
ihn macht ihr so viel content denkst du
diese nicole dick ich finde es sieht so
aus als wird die singen oder nicht
sondern ja aber was soll denn sonst
machen ja dieses für diesen dies
irgendetwas mit dem diskus ja es ist
nicht die idee ist ja aber ich werde
jetzt nicht so geschrieben dass es die
mit den dessous
ich sag dir mal den anfangsbuchstaben k
könnte ja also wenn er die nicht
erkannte dann wüsste ich auch nicht mehr
aber ist sehr sympathisch kann ich nur
sagen ehrlich wir machen weiter mit
demnächst also ich finde es jetzt bist
du eigentlich ganz gut und zwar werden
denn die beiden ihr lesen
ich dachte kennt sich aus
du kannst bis jetzt alle außer ein also
die asse beim musical i gefolgt zudem
bei instagram volk zu den fuchsien immer
an wie die daher finde ich nicht gut die
kennst du aber nicht oder kommt bekannt
vor
was könnte diese machen außer sich die
haare abzurasieren die können aber
singen oder mainz ist eine deutsche oder
amerikanische regisseur in amerikanische
oder deutsche klausner deutsche und was
macht ihn so schminken blocken job
schminken tut die sich nicht oder also
kennt sie nicht mehr lina doch aber den
damen ist jetzt hier ein gefallen
foto mit längerem als ungemein erkennt
dass sorgen sich kann ich das für die
auch mal wenn dieses 400.000 macht dann
lass dir deine ganze server passieren
nein und zum schluss haben wir noch
einen dem müsstest du eigentlich kennen
den kennt man eigentlich als junge und
zwar hier
kennst du nicht nein aber noch nicht ich
kenne die nicht wisse was macht ihr
nicht in der schule mancher so über
youtube neven da kommen wir zum gl dass
alex bruder und wahren gefühle verdienst
du jetzt scheint liefert die frage nicht
aber ihr redet nicht über youtube einer
schule
das macht man doch heutzutage oder wo
aus welchem land kommt der england
england manche so what's up einem von
ihnen lernen und das macht er so wie
mode so ist er geht auf jeden fall in
die maschine so hart tutorials und so
wie ich sagen oder guck mal ganz genau
wie ich finde er ist aber schon ganz gut
gestylt oder mode jetzt so daily mail
zur planung modus so was halt mode
stylen schuhe meister rappen tut er
nicht oder sie gar nicht so aus oder
alles klar du kannst du nicht ins korn
ich finde im mehrin hat auf jeden fall
richtig gute gesichtserkennung und kann
sich auf jeden fall das ein oder andere
gesicht auch richtig gut merken
das war es mit dem video wird natürlich
es hat euch gefallen
falls es der fall ist lässt man dann
nach oben da wie gesagt bei 100000 likes
duffy mit komplett die ganzen haare
abrasieren das war mir nicht gedacht
auf jeden fall checkt instagram und
snapshot ab mehrin heißem instagram
berlin.de und hastig wieder ungehemmt
und ja ansonsten wünsche euch noch ein
angenehm tag wir sehen uns morgen wieder
nichts da kommen fünf videos auf euch zu
ich freue mich auf die auf besonderes
sondern ja was in mein name wenig
abrasiert und churchill